foreign
[Music]
welcome to this live session from the
world Science Festival we haven't done
one of these live sessions in a long
time and those of our Die Hard fans will
recognize the background
from the pandemic days this is where we
were doing most of our work back in
those dark days of a couple years ago
but it is great to be back and having a
live conversation here today and we're
going to be focusing on some really
wonderful work that's happening in two
separate but related because everything
is related when it comes to fundamental
physical ideas wonderful work that's
taking place in the Arenas of
gravitational wave physics and also in
the long quest to understand what we
affectionately refer to as the dark side
of the universe dark matter and dark
energy and it really strikes me that
both of these subjects while they're
right there at the Cutting Edge they
each have this really
wonderful long history that goes way
back in time into the
1900s I mean gravitational waves was an
idea that Einstein himself was
developing and kicking around
back in 1916 1918 in fact
we have a wonderful little
representation of some of the papers
that Einstein wrote I don't know if we
can even just quickly bring those up on
the screen I don't know if Josh
our visual magic maker can do it I feel
like Dave Portnoy talking to Frankie uh
there we go so um thank you Josh so
there is a paper from 1916 where
Einstein really first began to think
about this idea that there might be
ripples in the fabric of space that
could travel outward and he wrote this
paper in 16 he actually corrected an
error in it in 1918 but the historical
record shows pretty clearly that
Einstein himself wasn't
really certain that these gravitational
waves would be real but we now know that
they are and we'll talk about some
recent work in that Arena as well the
second topic that we'll talk about in
the program here today
dark matter and dark energy well Dark
Matter itself has a long history going
way back to Fritz Wiki via Reuben way
back you know many decades ago and you
know the funny thing is although it's
not that funny we still don't really
know what dark matter and dark energy
actually are even though they are
profoundly woven into our understanding
of the universe our physical theories
rely upon these Concepts in a really
deep way and so it's about time that we
can be a little bit more specific about
what dark matter and dark energy
actually are and we'll be talking the
second half of the program about new
work that's going to help us to do that
so let's Jump Right In and let me
introduce our our first guest who is
Kiara mingarelli from Yale
and she is an assistant professor of
physics member of the nanograph
collaboration which as she will describe
has
you know over 150 160 maybe even 170
scientists I understand it
and this Consortium is discussing and
examining and exploring gravitational
waves through a novel technique that she
will describe Pulsar timing and she was
among the scientists who analyzed 15
years of observations of this sort using
some of the world's largest radio
telescopes and if you were following a
news relatively recently just in the
last handful of weeks you know that
there was an announcement where the
nanograph collaboration came out with
some very exciting results so let's get
right to it and talk to Chiara about
this wonderful observational team in
this experiment welcome Cara how are you
hi Brian I'm very well thanks it's so
great to be here thanks for having me
well thank you thank you for joining us
and and you know
um maybe just start with a little little
bit of background so you are now at yeah
where did you do your undergraduate
graduate work and was it focused on the
kinds of things that you're now studying
as a researcher
it's all related so I did my
undergraduate degree at Carleton
University in Ottawa Canada and I did a
double major in math and physics because
there was no astrophysics program and I
wanted to make sure that I had a really
solid mathematical basis for graduate
school because I knew right away that I
wanted to study black holes so I figured
I would take the most difficult program
I could find and if I could do that then
I could do astrophysics so that was
really good preparation for graduate
school which I attended first at the
University of Bologna in Italy and I did
their master's degree in gravitation and
cosmology and then I went to the UK for
graduate school for my PhD at the
University of Birmingham in the UK
and so Birmingham was a great choice
because they had a ligo group before it
was cool to work on ligo right yeah so
these are you say there was a long
period of time we'll talk a little bit
about ligo where people working online
it was like Hey it ain't gonna happen
guys what are you wasting your time on
I have had those conversations yes
absolutely so uh it was you know
challenging and exciting to be uh you
know on the ground floor for some of the
first papers that were written
especially in my field of Pulsar timing
and nanograph
um and so after that I did a postdoc at
Caltech and then Max Planck and I spent
the last few years in New York City at
the Simons Foundation at their Center
for computational astrophysics wonderful
place right it's fantastic have you
visited it oh many many times now
disclaimer they are one of our funders
so I guess I'm supposed to acknowledge
that but independent of that it's a
spectacular place oh my God yes you know
beautiful facilities bringing together
top Minds to investigate wonderful ideas
across the board and Sciences so yeah I
mean what a tremendous way to contribute
to the world after you've had great
success in the business world I wish
that was a model that everybody took but
yeah for sure I I agree Jim and Marilyn
are wonderful and it's even great that
they haunt the hallways and talk to
people and ask them about their work
they're they're really wonderful
philanthropists yeah and they're so
genuinely interested in everything
that's going on so it's really it is
great so you spent a couple years at
Simon's and then from there did you go
to yeah was that the I had um I had a
joint position between the University of
Connecticut and
um and the Flatiron Institute still
which is part of the Simon's foundation
and then after three years I
transitioned to a position at Yale yeah
great and and so you said you had an
initial interest in in black holes
where did the interest in in
gravitational waves start to materialize
gravitational waves to me always kind of
like when I heard about it it seems a
little bit like magic right and so if
when we're coming through the room right
now going from the ceiling into the
floor we're sitting across from each
other we would get closer together and
further away and then closer together
and further away in the other direction
making these plus and cross patterns and
we're not moving it's the fabric of
space-time itself that's moving and if
that doesn't Inspire awe and curiosity
like I don't I don't know what would you
can also think about it in terms of time
delays right times being delayed by that
much or space and thanks to Einstein as
you pointed out earlier we know that
space and time are intrinsically related
to each other so
um just the way that you think about it
depends on what experiment you want to
do sure so Einstein you know I mean his
big breakthrough of course
what made Einstein Einstein was the
general theory of relativity where he
reformulated gravity as our audience
knows all too well in terms of curvature
in the space-time Fabric and then and
then you're right the sort of natural
next step is if if space can warp and
curve maybe those curves can undulate
and I think we have a little
animated sequence that illustrates what
you just mentioned in terms of the
stretching and compression if you are
Downstream from a gravitational wave so
if we could yeah there we go so tell us
what we're seeing here
so here we're seeing two compact objects
and these could be anything from
supermassive black holes to Stellar Mass
black holes that are a few times the
mass of the Sun this could even be
neutron stars you'll the only way that
you know the difference is is towards
the end if these two objects can deform
each other and act on each other then
they're neutron stars because those are
squishy whereas black holes are hard and
those are going to fight each other till
the very end and then just merge Without
Really deforming each other before they
merge and then if you're Downstream from
these gravitational waves as you
mentioned
they affect you right so here in the
earth slightly exaggerated
not to scale not to scale at all which
uh is really the operative observation
because when you do calculations the
stretching and the squeezing from a
typical astrophysical gravitational wave
would be less than an atomic diameter
which of course makes measuring
gravitational waves such a challenge and
of course I think as people have been
following this field we'll get to your
work with nanograph in a moment but the
headline grabbing results initially came
from ligo that you made reference to so
can you just tell us how how does ligo
go about trying to detect these tiny
compressions and extensions that come
from a passing gravitational wave
yeah so ligo is sensitive to
gravitational waves that come from
merging Stellar Mass black holes and a
very high frequencies in terms of the
spectrum so one thing that we haven't
mentioned that but it might make sense
to talk about is this difference between
the electromagnetic spectrum and so
light that we can see and the
gravitational wave spectrum and they're
not the same thing it this blew my mind
when I started learning about
gravitational waves that it's a
completely different way about observing
the universe so on the gravitational
wave spectrum we also have high
frequencies and low frequencies just
like light experiments we have x-rays
and gamma rays at the high energy end
and then we have
um
radio waves and infrared radiation at
lower frequencies and so just like that
in terms of gravitational waves at high
frequencies we have the ligo sources so
Stellar Mass black holes and so ligo
works by an incoming laser that gets
split into and those laser beams then
travel down this L-shaped it's called an
interferometer and that's because the
light interferes with itself so the
light hits two mirrors and then comes
back and interferes with itself
destructively so you don't see any light
if those two arm lengths are exactly the
same size and they're about four
kilometers long
and so if a gravitational wave passes
what happens is that one arm becomes a
little bit longer and the other one
becomes shorter and then one arm becomes
shorter and the other one becomes longer
and you end up doing this this ligo
dance right as your interferometer uh
starts moving around and as the
gravitation is go to higher and higher
frequencies people really start dancing
right and so that's the way that you
detect these things a little animation
of that just to underscore what you were
saying I mean we have in the United
States two of these devices one in
Louisiana the other in Washington state
so you can sort of see the ale it just
sort of went by the screen oh yeah there
you go you're talking about the laser
light it goes you know down one tunnel
when that laser reaches the far end
really refine mirrors bounce it back and
this is happening in both arms as you
mentioned the light recombines at the
vertex and depending on the relative
lengths of the arms it'll affect the
signature that you find and that was you
know an amazing device to build for a
long time nothing happened until
September was it September 14th I guess
it was of 2015 at was it 5 51 in the
morning something like that you know the
first detection
sensitivity to Stellar Mass tens of
times the masses of the sun I think it
was 230 solar mass block holes that's
right and do we have that do we have
that little signal I think we may even
be able to remind people of what that
looked like and sounded like Josh can
you bring that up by any chance
well maybe I can I can do it for you
yeah do it for us first I can do it for
you you hear yours the real one here we
go
so the the frequency changes really
quickly towards the end of um the
binary's lifetime and so if you could
hear it and with ligo it's very cool
because the signals are in the human
audible range it would sound like
beautiful and we don't even need the uh
the actual data that was close enough
our experiment was less had less money
than ligo so we've had to make do with
dances and making our own sound effects
ligo is very fancy now and so your
approach though is I I find it
incredibly
creative and and again just we mentioned
earlier on but how many people are
working on on nanograph
well in the U.S and Canada there are um
just under 200 scientists that are
working on this project and we've been
working on it for about 15 years but in
Europe there's a team the European
Pulsar timing array there's now the
Indian Pulsar timing array there's the
Australian Pulsar timing array and the
Chinese Pulsar timing array and so we've
been taking data for over a decade with
hundreds of scientists looking for the
signal of merging supermassive black
holes so clearly pulsars and Pulsar
timing is is vital as you made reference
to it a couple times there so just
you can just fill us in on the approach
that you guys are taking to detect these
ripples in the fabric of space-time
right and and I agree with you I wish
that it were my idea you've called it my
experiment but this is an experiment
that was thought of uh in the late 70s
first from
um for lasers coming back from
spacecraft so the the original idea was
actually
proposed um by sending spacecraft out
into the distant solar system and then
the light signals that were sent back
could be perturbed by gravitational
waves but of course those signals
wouldn't be stable enough and so then
um the next idea was like well you know
we know pulsars exist so what if we were
to use the flashes from pulsars so
pulsars are these Cosmic lighthouses and
they're these very dense neutron stars
they're about one and a half times the
mass of the Sun and they're roughly the
size of Manhattan and they spin around
so fast it's as if you took all of the
mass of the Sun and then a bit and put
it in a blender
right it spins around hundreds of times
a second not just any blender it'd have
to be a Vitamix oh I don't know I don't
know do they sponsor this yeah
after that yeah so it spins around it's
incredibly high speed incredible like
like a lighthouse it's flashing
us every time it goes around I think we
do have something that sort of
illustrates that that's right but you're
saying that these are incredibly stable
systems so that they're basically like a
clock right there's a subset of pulsars
called millisecond pulsars which are
incredibly accurate clocks in fact until
the early 2010s they were better than
atomic clocks and I believe it was 2012
when atomic clocks caught up but before
that you could set your watch to a
pulsar and only lose about 100
nanoseconds over a decade wow that's how
good they are and they need to be that
good because these gravitational waves
while they look impressively large in
animations are very very small they can
stretch and squash the fabric of
space-time to one part and a million
billion so that's something like 10
meters per light year but I'm not used
to thinking about real quantities in
terms of light years like I don't have a
physical sense of how far a light there
is but I do have a sense of nanoseconds
right so if I say that these
gravitational waves distort space time
by a hundred nanoseconds over a decade
you know that that's small I feel like
that gives you the right the right sense
so we can also thank Einstein for that
and and so you're then using
these naturally existing objects these
pulsars as your clocks yeah that's right
and then you want to see how the ticking
of those clocks may be affected by
gravitational waves that are permeating
the universe because that's the basic
idea that's right that when the
gravitational waves Transit through our
galaxy The pulsars get a little bit
closer to the Earth and then a little
bit further away and then a little bit
closer and a little bit further away and
that changes the timing of these Ultra
stable clocks the signals from these
Ultra stable lighthouses arrive a little
bit early and then a little bit late and
then early and then late and that's how
we know that the signal is there and
it's not just in one Pulsar it's in a
whole array of pulsars so in the
nanograph experiment there are 68
millisecond pulsars in our 15-year data
release and those results were uh were
what was announced on June 29th and
those 68 are the ones that are
particularly stable I mean they're
they're selected for that for that
reason that's right and and so whereas
ligo using you know the interferometer
you know with the two four kilometer
long tunnels that we discussed before is
really sensitive to the motion of black
holes at maybe 10 20 30 solar masses 30
times the mass of the Sun this approach
is sensitive to a completely different
range of black hole masses right so what
what's The Sweet Spot or the sweet Arena
that this approach would be sensitive to
that's right this approach is sensitive
to black holes that are a hundred
million to a billion times the mass of
the Sun and these black holes would be
about the size of our entire solar
system they are gargantuan they can be a
thousand times more massive than our own
supermassive black hole here in the
center of the Galaxy called Sagittarius
A star and so but it's not just one of
these it's two of these gargantuan black
holes that are now slowly orbiting each
other
and to compare this experiment to ligo
ligo can see the last fraction of a
second of one of these black hole
mergers but the gravitational waves
right that's also a very uh slowed down
right it's a fraction of a second of a
whoop yeah and so with Pulsar timing the
gravitation away from these super
massive black holes are so strong
that you can detect them 25 million
years before they merge
so these right it's crazy it's
absolutely crazy 25 million years of
signal so we're not going to miss them
right when we can find the individual in
spiraling supermassive black holes
they'll be there for a while yeah so
that like you know
fraction of a second that the wave
rolled by in September of 2015 we had to
be there to catch it yeah you got 25
million years to catch yours that's
right and that's just one of them but
these mergers take so long that over
this 25 million year time span there's
another galaxy that's going to have a
merger with another galaxy and their
black holes are going to start merging
and this is going to happen all over the
universe and so because the mergers take
so long at any given moment in our
universe we have hundreds of thousands
of these merging supermassive blockable
binary systems and so
that signal is so loud that it swamps
the signal of any individual source and
what we can detect is this gravitational
wave background and that's the primary
source of gravitational waves that we
were looking for with the nanograph
experiment and so now we have evidence
that this gravitational wave background
exists
and so this is like if if you walk into
a restaurant that's crowded and every
table is having their own conversation
you sort of hear this murmur which is
the collective Union of all the sound
waves emanating from each of those
individual conversations you're sort of
hearing the murmur of all of these
individual black hole mergers at all
these different locations in the
universe Blended together into a
background hum like sound is that is
that a way to think about it that's
right you can think about it that way
that's great you can think about it as a
symphony and these are the very you know
low frequency instruments that I like to
think about it as the end of yoga class
whenever one chance
um
together it's a very low frequency
steady ohm and these are our very stable
supermassive black holes that are taking
their time they've got lots of time to
merge we're not worried about missing
one of these signals so why what was why
did I hate to frame it this way and I
should have a more elegant way of asking
this question but why did it take 15
years was it collecting the data was it
refining the analysis what were you
doing for 15 years
well I mean to put it you know we we do
live in an elegant Universe thank
[Laughter]
you so um so it took 15 years because
well I mean first of all we didn't know
how loud the signal would be and our
most sensitive frequency you know comes
at one of our total observing time and
so with 15 years we can access
frequencies of around one and a half
nanohertz and so we weren't sure and a
nanohertz is a billionth of a Hertz
right and it never hurts so it's like to
take a step back if I had two
supermassive black holes at one
nanohertz that's an orbital period of 30
years
so 30 years to complete one orbit is one
nanohertz wow and so these supermassive
black holes generate gravitational waves
that have wavelengths that are light
years long
and so it's going to take a very very
long time to measure you know one signal
or the superposition of all of the
signals which is what creates the
gravitational wave background and so
these signals are impossible to detect
with ligo for two reasons number one
they are
you know a thousand billion times lower
frequency than what ligo can detect yeah
number two
if anyone here is an expert they have
this uh innermost stable circular orbit
so the last orbit that they can take
before they merge will happen at a micro
Hertz
and so the black holes just merge before
they ever get into the ligo band right
and for any aficionados even before they
get into the Lisa band
so these black holes will you know spend
25 million years in spiraling and then
they're done but they they don't go into
different detectors
and and during this period I mean with
ligo
as you made mention there is a long
stretch of time where it wasn't clear
that there was going to be a positive
result were you guys in a similar frame
of mind during that period of time or
were you like hey no we're we're getting
there we're going to get there it's just
a matter of time before we'll have
enough data to be able to announce a
discovery
like any good collaboration we were very
enthusiastic and very self-critical so
in fact if you take the information of
you know what we know now and look back
in time of course we could have seen the
signal that we have now earlier but in
fact when we started seeing signals that
looked like a gravitation wave
background we were like no it's too
early that signal is too loud that can't
that can't be real we have to get rid of
all of this noise and we kept going back
to say like oh no this is this is
Jupiter's orbit this is impossible that
you know this is what's really causing a
gravitational wave background and then
we kept trying to hide this signal and
and explain it away by using everything
else because of course extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
and so the the detection working group
that nanograph led by Sarah vigiland did
an enormously thorough job in terms of
fully exploring all of the possibilities
of everything else the signal could be
and so in fact when looking for this
particular signal there's two parts to
it there's an amplitude of the
gravitational wave background and that's
set by the astrophysics of how the
supermassive black holes merge how many
of them there are how massive they are
the frequencies they're at and then the
other part is this very interesting
additional correlation that happens
between the Pulsar Pairs and so it's not
just that they all have this amplitude
in it but some of them are more
correlated than others on the sky and
this is another prediction from general
relativity and so we'd have to we had to
see both that special correlation and
that amplitude and all the pulsars and
this with the nanograph 15-year data is
the first time we've ever seen evidence
for that spatial correlation so we know
for sure that there's a gravitation wave
background in those data
and so
enroute to this result when ligo
announced was there a sense of they beat
us to the punch or does or was it a
sense of yes gravitational waves are
absolutely there and now we just need to
find our signal and a rededication to
the program because of their success
there was always a friendly rivalry
between Pulsar timing arrays and ligo
and of course we were so happy when ligo
made their announcement
a lot of the uh nanograph members uh
that are now at similar um you know
career levels as me we were post-docs at
Caltech and at JPL when this
announcement happened and so we were
just so thrilled and people who work in
gravitational waves you know at this
point if we've been around for a while
you've written papers for ligo and I
certainly have and a lot of my
colleagues have as well and so we were
all ecstatic I mean there was certainly
absolutely no bitterness it was more you
know the tide raises All Ships and now
people will finally believe that
gravitational waves are real
and so you know all of these doubts that
you were expressing I'm sure a lot of
scientists felt even for ligo you know
before you know you turn on your
experiment and you keep trying to tune
it and get more data and get a better
signal and when it finally happens it's
a huge amount of relief but before
there's a healthy amount of skepticism
and you know I think that's important
for Science and and so now that you have
a signal are you guys certain you know
the precise source of it or is there
some
uncertainty in what might actually be
going on
so right now we have a three sigma
detection
um evidence for the gravitational wave
background and that means that there's a
false alarm so a probability of this of
roughly you know once in a thousand
years this could happen where the stars
align in this particular way and it's
not a real signal so we're fairly
confident that it's real however at this
moment because we're at three sigma and
maybe not five Sigma which is you know
every few minutes right yeah exactly the
gold standard for particle physics the
signal is a little bit squishy
and that means that you can kind of take
it and shape it into different forms
which means that actually supermassive
black holes match the signal but so do
primordial backgrounds from the early
universe so moments after the big bang
There were these Quantum fluctuations
that could have been blown up to the
size of the universe and created
gravitational waves that we could
potentially be detecting today the
drawback there is that the current
models put those primordial
gravitational waves at about 10 orders
of magnitude below where we're at right
now and so it's very unlikely if the
universe works the way we think it does
that that's what's generating the signal
another potential source is cosmic
strings and if only I had an expert to
ask what cosmic strings are I I would
love to have a kind of gold standard
explanation of cosmic strings I get
asked this all the time and I'm woefully
ill-equipped to explain cosmic strings
oh I think you're a little too
self-deprecating there but um but maybe
I'll just give it as a you know an off
the cuff you know shot I mean what are
cosmic strings well
um you know the idea that I like to make
a reference to when talk about cosmic
strings is something everybody's
familiar with which is uh you know we
have dogs
and the dogs you know unfortunately have
to be on a leash at some point in order
to keep them from running away and if a
dog happens to walk around a tree its
leash will get caught up in Winding
around this particular structure
and because of that the leash can't just
collapse to an Unwound State directly
and the amazing thing is that that
analogy is relevant to the universe
because the universe is filled with
fields
and the value of a field its numerical
value can wind around an analogous Loop
in the space of possible values for that
field and if a field winds around in
that manner just like the dog leash
winding around the field can't actually
stay in the lowest energy configuration
everywhere as you go closer and closer
to the center something's got to give
and what gives in this case is there's
an energy that winds up being
concentrated in the center of this field
Loop and that energy sort of like in the
shape of a tree
is a linear structure of energy and that
linear structure of energy is what we
call a cosmic string and it's an idea
that it goes way back into the studies
of field Theory there's a version of it
that comes from my field which is not
cosmic strings but String Theory it's
the same word same basic idea of a
linear object normally we think of super
strings as little tiny objects that are
responsible for the particles of matter
but the late great Joe palchinsky and
others showed that super strings
themselves can get stretched out by
Cosmic expansion and become very long
filaments similar to the string that it
just described to you a moment ago so
the possibility is that our universe
might be filled with these long
oscillating string like objects which
would shake the fabric of space yielding
gravitational waves and as you make
reference to they could in principle be
the explanation the kind of signature
that you are seeing that's right
actually wonderful thank you so much for
that explanation I'm gonna you and I
have a dog her name is Coco Bean the
love machine so I'm certainly by the
name yes exact well she's very very
sweet
so yeah so cosmic strings are are the
next explanation but really we're gonna
need more data in order to understand
what sourcing the gravitational wave
background and so that's what you're
focused on on now is it is it just
Gathering more
and and more data and or more and more
because you made reference to a lot of
Pulsar timing groups around the world
has your success now inspired others to
join in the collaboration to be part of
the fund
it's not our success that has inspired
them in fact we've all been working
together for many many years uh trying
to you know find this signal and so
we've been collaborating working
together sharing data under the auspices
of what we call the international Pulsar
timing array yeah and so that's uh that
collaboration is really important for
the next steps because if we see a
gravitational wave background using
telescopes and pulsars in the northern
hemisphere the natural question is what
do you see in the Southern Hemisphere
and if the background really is coming
from sources in all directions you need
to understand what's going on on the
other side of the sky and so
characterizing the background and making
maps of it is really what's going to be
what's next so right now we've turned on
the experiment
we've seen something that looks very
isotropic or the same in all directions
but the next step is then to try to
really focus the signal and understand
where is it coming from are there hot
spots in one part of the sky and then
what I think is going to be really
interesting is what happens if we find a
hot spot and then we take a telescope
and point it at that hot spot and look
at it and what's exciting but not super
interesting is if we see lots of merging
supermassive black holes there but what
would be fascinating is what if we don't
see anything
what would you uh
say at that point
I mean it could be cosmic strings it
could be some sort of cluster some sort
of Loops that are evaporating by
emitting gravitational waves I I mean I
think that this is where things get
really fun I think that you could
probably write 100 papers overnight
about what would cause gravitational
waves to come out of nothing it could
still be super massive black holes that
don't have any gas or Stars around them
but I think that that's very unlikely
well I mean it's uh it's amazing work
and again I just come back to my initial
comment which is that it's uh you know I
think you can take part credit for
everything that's happening here it's
just such an amazingly smart idea the
the idea is brilliant and it's not my
idea
um you know it goes back to the late 70s
the early 80s
um but there were some really smart
people back then and there are today and
thankfully many of them are my
colleagues who are responsible for
leading the analysis timing these
pulsars I mean my colleagues that are
the radio astronomers that time these
pulsars have gone back to telescopes
every two weeks for the last 15 years to
time these pulsars it's just a huge
labor of love at that point and so we're
just so excited to have this first
result and can't wait to report back
when we find the individual supermassive
black hole mergers or something else
yeah hugely exciting you know making the
universe in essence your gravitational
wave detector as opposed to trying to
build one here on planet Earth so I
don't think we could do it even if we
wanted to hi is there something that has
a wavelength of light years yeah yeah no
I'm more referring to I mean the heroic
work of ligo is is wondrous but you know
that work is all focused and trying to
Shield this machine to make sure that
the only thing that can shake it would
be a gravitational wave you know in the
approach that you guys are taking it's
just already there and it's just a
matter of mining the information that's
coming to us here on planet Earth so
best of luck going forward to you and
the entire
team and uh I think we all look forward
to hearing the exciting next results
that you guys uncover Kiara so thanks so
much thank you wonderful thank you so
much all right so with that now let's
move on to the second topic that I
mentioned that we would be talking about
today which is you may have been
following that the recent launch of the
Euclid mission to try to get some
insight into dark matter and dark energy
and to discuss that joining us now from
Pasadena California is Jason Rhodes
who has played a significant part in
Euclid as NASA's science lead on the
project he's senior research scientist
at NASA's jet propulsion laboratory a
visiting scholar at the California
Institute of Technology in addition is
Deputy project scientist for NASA's
Nancy Grace Roman telescope which is
scheduled to launch in 2027 and that
telescope as we will discuss will also
study aspects of the Dark Universe so
Jason thank you for joining us welcome
how's everything going great thank you
for inviting me I really enjoyed the
first half the program I learned a lot
about nanograph and gravitational waves
and their announcement came out just
days before Euclid's launch so it was a
really exciting week for me hearing
about that and then watching the Euclid
launch a couple weeks ago oh fantastic
so why don't we jump right into it so
Dark Matter Dark Energy these are ideas
that most everybody who follows science
even at a cursory level have heard about
I think we should just spend perhaps a
moment giving a little bit of background
so
Dark Matter an idea that goes way back
can you give us sort of a thumbnail
sketch of what dark matter is and why
people have introduced this idea into
physics yes so uh some of the first
evidence for Dark Matter came from as
you said before Fritz zwiki who is
astronomer uh right here in Pasadena
California at Caltech and he was looking
at the Motions of galaxies relative to
each other and he found that the Motions
of galaxies couldn't be described by
just looking at the stars and the gas in
the galaxies there had to be something
else making the galaxies heavier and so
that was the the first evidence of dark
matter but the first really strong
evidence of Dark Matter came a few
decades later from an astronomer named
Vera Rubin who was looking at the
rotation curves of galaxies and she was
looking at how galaxies rotate and what
she found was that Galaxies have to be
uh filled with stuff that we don't see
they have to be filled with something
other than the star cars and the gas in
them to explain how fast they're
rotating and if you fast forward then a
few more decades we've got a lot of
evidence for the fact that dark matter
is out there in the universe and it's
about six times more Dark Matter than
the normal matter and the normal matter
is everything that makes up Stars
galaxies you me planets everything we
can see touch and feel but we know that
there's this dark matter out there
forming the structure of the universe
yeah for Vera Ruben's work I like to
describe it in terms of you know people
are familiar you have a bicycle wheel
that has water on it as it spins the
water will fly off the wheel similarly
as the Galaxy spin the Stars should have
been flung off but they're not flung off
so there has to be an additional
gravitational pull that's tethering them
to the Galaxy and what would that come
from some form of matter giving rise to
gravity but matter that we don't see and
there comes the idea of dark matter so
this this idea is quite old in fact you
know I think many of us at some point
even if Dark Matter isn't our specialty
have dabbled in it my very first paper
as a graduate student was on a dark
matter candidate a dark matter proposal
it was like the the simplest way to
start doing physics research a while
back was dream up some potential
particle that might be the dark matter
and do some analysis to see how you
might detect it or whether it fits the
bill and actually could provide the dark
matter but where are we then in going
Beyond wild imaginings and actually
figuring out what the dark matter is
made of
so there's two separate tracks uh for
studying dark matter and one is dark
matter detectors looking for a particle
of Dark Matter here on Earth uh so I'm
not involved in that aspect but that's a
really exciting aspect because of course
we want to know what the Dark Matter
particle is and they're incredibly hard
to detect but we think that there's a
number of Dark Matter particle
candidates that we should eventually be
able to detect the other aspect of
studying dark matter and the one that
I've been involved in for my entire
career is using astrophysical techniques
to study the amount and distribution of
dark matter in the universe and we know
that there's the dark matter because as
you discussed in the first half of the
show gravity bends space that's what
general relativity tells us and dark
matter since it's the most of the mass
of the universe does a lot of bending of
space and we can detect that bit Space
by looking at the uh
shapes of distant galaxies so while the
galaxies themselves what we see are
normal or visible matter encoded in the
shapes and positions of those galaxies
is an incredible amount of information
about the structure of the universe and
the structure of dark matter
and so just to be specific just in case
anyone missed the first half of your
answer we don't know
what the dark matter is no one's
actually captured any of it so
everything that we're doing is sort of
an indirect approach to try to find it
and your indirect approach is saying
what would the impact of the dark matter
be on for instance the trajectory of
light beams as they're traveling through
space to reach us what would the impact
of this dark matter Beyond those
trajectories and working backwards to
map out where that dark matter must be
to account for what we see
that's exactly right so in the absence
of Dark Matter uh between us and distant
galaxies the light from those galaxies
would take a straight uh path to us but
instead the light is curved by the
curvature of space and so what that
means is when we measure the shape of a
distant Galaxy we don't measure the
shape as it actually is our observed
shape has some Distortion and by looking
for a coherent pattern of those
distortions across hundreds thousands or
in the case of the Euclid Mission
billions of galaxies spread across the
sky we can look at those distortions and
we can use that to map out the position
of the dark matter and by looking
further and further away further and
further back in time we can look at how
the distribution of dark matter changes
over Cosmic time and that distribution
of dark matter changing over Cosmic time
is something that tells us about dark
energy which is something that we're
gonna I think discuss soon as well
absolutely before we get there why don't
we get right to the Euclid Mission so
recently launched maybe you can just
take us through a little bit of the
history of the mission the recent launch
and where where it is right now
great yes so uh the Euclid Mission uh
has at in part of the Euclid Mission has
its Origins uh over at Caltech where I
was
um visiting uh postdoc in 2002 and with
a couple of other people we said what
would be the best way to design a
satellite to study the distribution of
dark matter and we fleshed this out and
uh we published a paper and then we
started to go to the various space
agencies and said we've got to build
this Mission and over the course of the
last 20 years I and others have
convinced space agencies around the
world that this is a very worthwhile
pursuit to build a telescope like this
and so Euclid is the first purpose-built
telescope that's going to study the
structure of the universe by looking for
these distortions of Galaxy shapes using
uh dark matter
I'm sorry sorry well I was going to say
it's a European and space agency-led
mission with uh Mission enabling
technology and other support from from
NASA which is where I come in uh and
right now the Euclid Consortium which
built the instruments the the two
cameras and uh built the uh uh ground
system which is the system of computers
and people which will analyze the data
this is about 2 000 people around the
world so it's one of the largest ever
astronomy collaborations uh and it's a
number of people that are just thrilled
and what you're seeing here is the the
Falcon 9 liftoff uh of Euclid just uh
about three weeks ago so that's the
SpaceX yeah this was a SpaceX launch uh
from Florida and there were several
hundred of us as we call ourselves
euclideans uh who went to watch uh the
launch and it was uh for me both an
exciting and emotional time because I've
been working on this project so long so
to to see the satellite leave the Earth
and head to uh what we call the LaGrange
two point this is where Euclid is now uh
it's a point uh that has equal
gravitational pull from the Sun
and the Earth it's beyond the moon and
so the reason we put the telescope there
is it's a very thermally stable position
in the solar system and what that means
is you can have the telescope so that
the same side of the telescope is always
uh pointing at the Sun so you don't have
heat gradients that are causing the
telescope to heat up and contract like
you do with for instance the Hubble
Space Telescope which orbits the earth
every 90 minutes so it's far enough to
be thermally stable and it's also far
enough that the Earth really isn't uh uh
out of the way or sorry is it in the way
right in terms of trying to view the
universe but it's close enough that we
can get back the data from the telescope
so it's about a million miles away it's
also where James Webb Telescope is
saying sort of a popular parking lot for
cutting incredibly popular there's a
number of other telescopes that have
gone there isa's plan satellite NASA's
wmap satellite most recent the James
Webb Space Telescope and you mentioned
the the room Roman telescope which will
launch in about 2027 and that'll go to
L2 as well it's an incredibly uh great
place to to put a telescope so is
everything gone smooth from so the
launch was when again uh July 1st July
1st so we're now a good three weeks in
uh it's it's reached the L2 point and I
guess it must have started to deploy the
antenna and whatever else it needs to do
and how's that going
so if people remember the uh there was a
lot of concern at the time of the jwst
launch because there were a lot of
deployments uh to uh deploy a sun shield
and other huge sun shield yeah that's
that's exactly right so Euclid is a
smaller uh and simpler telescope partly
because it's observing in Optical and
near infrared and so it doesn't need the
the complexity that jwst has and so
there's only a single deployment uh with
Euclid and that was uh deploying an
antenna that downlinks the data and uh
that deployment has gone well and we're
now commissioning uh the instruments an
optical camera to take pictures that
allows us to get uh the shapes of
galaxies and an infrared camera that
will take both images and Spectra that
will allow us to get the distances to
galaxies and everything's going uh well
so far and by the end of this year we
hope to start taking uh data surveying
the sky to look for these Galaxy shapes
and positions so you say so it's about
another five months or so away before
the the actual research will get
underway and Earnest yeah so around the
December time frame we hope to start uh
surveying the sky and Euclid's got a
relatively simple survey pattern in that
it's just going to survey about a third
of the sky over six years and so uh this
animation here what you're seeing is as
we're filling in spots those are each
year those are the spots that uh on the
sky that Euclid is going to survey
go ahead how many years will it be in
operation it'll be an operation for six
years and then allow us to survey the
best 15 000 Square degrees of the sky so
that's about a third of the sky and the
idea of why we're serving about a third
of the sky is when you look at this
animation what you see uh going across
the center there that's our own Milky
Way galaxy yeah and that is full of dust
and stars that obscures a lot of the
extra Galactic Universe so we're not
going to use Euclid to look there
because we want to look at these very
distant galaxies uh upon which is
encoded the information about dark
matter and dark energy right
um and and so
comparing this to to say James Webb
James Webb is looking in a much smaller
part of the sky looking more deeply and
with the high degree of of refinement
being the goal would you characterize
Euclid as more
um the broad brush
information about a wider swath of the
sky at less depth from planet Earth
absolutely so Euclid is incredibly
complementary to a telescope like the
James Webb Space Telescope James Webb's
got a bigger mirror it's got more
instruments and it can look uh much
deeper at a very small area of the sky
and so I think a good uh way to think
about this is that the James Webb
Telescope has a field of view that is
the area of the sky that it looks at is
similar to the field of view of the
Hubble Space Telescope yeah which has
been operating for 30 years so the
Hubble Space Telescope has looked very
deeply and in very great resolution at
about 50 square degrees of the sky 15
minutes 30 years 50 square degrees Yeah
five zero and the whole Sky Is 40 000
some Square degrees right so Euclid will
survey 50 square degrees in its first
week of survey operations so it won't
survey as deep as Hubble has gone
whereas James Webb's face telescope can
go and it won't survey uh at a higher
resolution but it's going to serve a
much greater area of the sky and in
addition to doing these studies that's
going to allow us and here you see how
Euclid just scans across the sky each uh
of those
um blocks is one observation of Euclid
about a half a square degree and it's
going to do about seven square degrees
uh per day
your total is just by comparison so 50
square degrees saying Hubble but you're
more like what 13
000 15 000 Square degrees over the
course of that six years wow and that's
going to allow us to survey uh very
accurate shapes for over a billion
galaxies an extremely accurate positions
for tens of millions of galaxies
and so in principle if you find
something worthy of a more detailed
observation you can get on
the phone and call James Webb and say
hey you guys might find it interesting
to focus in on this part of the sky is
that is there that kind of crosstalk
that's possible oh absolutely uh one of
the things that's going to be amazing
about Euclid is uh by surveying the sky
uh this much of the sky it's going to be
an excellent finder telescope to find
rare uh objects uh if there's only a
handful of some objects uh in the
universe because they're the first uh of
their kind to form in the very early
Universe uh Euclid will be able to find
them and then say to James Webb you
should follow this up in more detail so
Euclid's going to be a treasure Trove of
data not just for people studying dark
matter and dark energy but across a wide
range of astrophysics and I think the
Euclid archive is going to be used uh
for decades to come by thousands of
astronomers all over the world yeah
that's remarkable well let's transition
a bit to Dark Energy we spent a bit of
time talking about Dark Matter dark
energy
you know it's a it's a related but
completely independent idea in many ways
whose history
goes goes way way back I mentioned a
little bit of the history of my early
remarks but I don't think I made note of
the fact that it was Einstein himself in
1917 who introduced into the equations
of the general theory of relativity the
cosmological constant motivated by
trying to make the universe static on
the largest of scales the cosmos of the
constant is a kind of dark energy in
this language so the idea goes back to
1917. maybe it can take us through a
little bit of the thinking perhaps more
recently about why dark energy has come
to the fore of the theoretical ideas
that we introduce and trying to
understand the cosmos well well sure as
you mentioned Einstein introduced this
to his equations for the purposes of
keeping a static universe and this was
just a few years before we found out
that the Universe was expanding in the
1920s and Einstein called the
introduction of this constant his his
biggest blunder and so from the 1920s
until the mid-1990s uh people assumed
that we had an expanding universe but a
universe that was slowing down due to
gravity uh gravity pulling things back
in and two separate teams in the 1990s
were trying to uh figure out how that
expansion was slowing down and they came
to the same conclusion the expansion
wasn't slowing down the expansion was
speeding up this was completely
counterintuitive because in a universe
with stuff matter Dark Matter normal
matter and gravity the gravity should be
slowing things down
something's pushing it apart and we
don't know what that is and I like to
say that dark energy is the name we give
to our ignorance of what's causing this
accelerating expansion we know it's
there but we don't uh really understand
the mechanism very well and there's a
lot of different theories there's a huge
space of theories
uh but uh things like Euclid will give
us a huge amount more data to constrain
those theories and perhaps narrow down
the the space of theories that still
explain the observations yes perhaps
worth noting it's a very good summary
but perhaps worth noting as well that in
Einstein's general relativity there's a
remarkable fact that matter that's
clumpy gives rise to attractive gravity
but energy that's diffuse and uniform
gives rise to repulsive gravity which
can push things apart which is why it
was introduced as you say when we came
to the startling result that not only is
the universe expanding but it's speeding
up in its expansion must be something
pushing outward now when people hear
these kinds of indirect
arguments
you know I I some would say you guys are
just jumping too quickly to a conclusion
you have a theory general relativity in
order to make it match the world as you
mentioned you introduce this idea that
you're ignorant of what it actually is
but mathematically it just seems to work
so there is a similarity between dark
matter and dark energy in that regard
you're trying to make our description
work then you introduce these patches I
mean Jim Peebles really fond of calling
them the patches that that seem to work
so how convinced are you
that dark energy is real that dark
matter is real and it's not just some
lack of our having the most refined
understanding that would explain what we
see without this dark stuff
well I have
answers and one is for dark matter and
the other is for for dark energy for the
dark matter when uh zwiki or Reuben were
doing their observations I think it was
really a patch like you described they
said Well there must be something there
to uh explain what we're seeing but in
more recent years the theory we have of
dark matter has become very predictive
that is it's not so much a patch we can
say we think Dark Matter uh is going to
cause the universe to behave like this
we're going to see gravitational lenses
we're going to see the growth of uh
structure formation that looks like this
and then we go and we measure it and we
see exactly what we predicted based on
our understanding uh of dark matter now
Dark Energy let me just quickly
interrupt in that one yeah I'm just
wondering and I don't know if you follow
but there have been some you know I
don't know Fringe explanations of some
of the observations that you're
describing by fiddling with the
fundamental Theory and equations in a
manner that doesn't necessarily need
dark matter I'm not convinced of these
ideas have you looked at all and or and
do you find them at all convincing or
are you pretty convinced that the more
conventional description with dark
matter is right
what I see a lot uh when people come up
with a new uh theory that doesn't
require dark matter is it's applicable
often to a specific set of observations
or a specific type of observations and
if we take globally all the observations
uh then it becomes very very hard to
have a universe with no dark matter and
so I have
growth of structure in the universe the
growth of Dark Matter structures I don't
know if they're able to queue up that
video
um and so uh what we're going to see in
this video is this is the very early
universe and it's almost completely
uniform yeah it's mostly dark matter but
spread very diffusely and as you
described the areas where there is more
Dark Matter are areas that grow over
time and become more and more dense and
that's what we're seeing in the red
areas here and the areas where there's
less stuff the stuff gets pulled out of
there and we're seeing the formation of
blue voids there and so this is what we
see happening in the universe and if we
trace the growth of structure in the
universe
uh we see end up with uh huge
conglomerations of mass and galaxies
clusters of galaxies and these big
filaments surrounded by voids that's
what we observe in the universe and one
of the things that's very interesting
about that is there's no way uh the
galaxies and clusters of galaxies we see
in the universe could form uh through
gravitational uh attraction if it wasn't
for the Dark Matter providing the
scaffolding the seeding of that there's
just not enough matter and so what we
would see is we'd see a very different
diffuse and different universe that
didn't form these structures so there's
really no way to describe I think all of
the observations we have that lead us to
think that there's dark matter with a
another theory now you said you're going
to give us a different perspective on
Dark Energy sure a different perspective
on Dark Matter so one sorry on Dark
Energy so one of the things that that we
talk about when we think about dark
energy is we assume uh or we can assume
that gen relativity is the correct
explanation for gravity and we've got a
century of observations that tells us
that but as scientists we don't want to
necessarily assume that so there are
plenty of ways that we can fiddle with
gravity that might explain some or all
of the observations we have related to
the expansion of the universe and so one
of the things that we're going to do
with Euclid is we're going to use two
separate probes of dark energy that
would behave differently these probes
would give different answers if it's our
theory of gravity that's incomplete
rather than gravity being complete and
us having to put in this new dark energy
repulsive Force so we're going to have
multiple ways of measuring uh the
expansion of the universe and the growth
of these structures that's going to
allow us to discern between different
inner theories of dark energy and
different theories of what we call
modified gravity so we're going to study
that too and that's what we might call
another free parameter and what we're
going to study so we're trying not to
assume the answer as Einstein did 100
years ago when he thought the universe
was static so we're going to study this
and see what the universe tells us
so if you were a betting person
I'm gathering you you'd be comfortable
putting your money down on the Dark
Matter question how comfortable would
you be putting your money down on the
dark energy
explanation
so the the uh difference there is I'd be
comfortable saying I think the universe
is uh dominated uh at least in the in
the mass budget by dark matter but uh I
would be uncomfortable uh putting my
money down on any one particular theory
of the Dark Energy but I would be pretty
comfortable putting my money down saying
yeah we live uh in a universe where the
expansion is accelerating uh in the last
half of the history of the universe yeah
but it's too early for me to say what I
think is causing that acceleration yeah
Euclid's coming at an incredibly uh
interesting time in cosmology because
there's some uh what we call tensions
between measurements of the very early
universe and the late Universe uh which
is what Euclid will measure and by late
Universe I mean the last half the
history of the universe right so if we
look at the early Universe around the
time of the cosmic microwave background
radiation and Trace the growth of
structures like I just showed you in
that video to what we see today it
matches up pretty well well but we're
starting to see at the few Sigma level
uh some discrepancies that may or may
not be because of our observations but
if they're not because of our problems
with our observations it could imply
that there's some new physics and that
the physics taking us from the early
Universe uh to the late universe is
incorrect or incomplete rather yeah no
the idea for example I guess is the is
the Hubble tension the uh measuring the
expansion rate early on and in the later
Universe measuring it and trying to
extrapolate or interpolate as you say
between the two and it doesn't quite
match up that's right and that could be
problems with the measurements but
what's more exciting for uh astronomers
and physicists is the possibility that
there's some underlying uh new physics
for us to discover and Euclid's going to
be fantastic as a data set for uh
Discerning between new physics and the
need for better observations because
it's going to provide the better
observations
and so how would you
compare we we discussed Euclid and and
Hubble and James Webb but how about
you know we made brief reference already
to some of the other missions that are
are coming up in the next few years how
does you could relate to those
well the next big space mission that has
uh dark energy as one of its primary
goals is uh NASA's Nancy Grace Roman
Space Telescope which uh we're hoping
will launch in about 2027. so I'm also
uh as you mentioned working on that uh
telescope and it's going to be very
complementary to Euclid for a number of
reasons one uh Roman is a bigger
telescope uh and has uh the capability
of looking deeper out into the universe
so it's going to take similar surveys to
what Hubble does or sorry to what Euclid
does yeah but it's going to take surveys
that are um smaller in area but deeper
in addition to uh taking these surveys
that are somewhat smaller in area it's
going to do something that Euclid is not
it's going to cover each area of the
survey more than once it's going to come
back to the area of the survey and look
at it uh with what we call multiple
filters or multiple colors and multiple
passes and this is going to provide a
really great way to have internal uh
cross checks on the data with Roman that
we won't have uh from Euclid the other
thing that's exciting about Roman is it
adds a third technique to studying dark
energy that Euclid is not going to use
and that's the looking at Supernova or
exploding so the original approach that
was right that's right so it's going to
be really Roman will be the definitive
experiment to use uh Supernova uh uh out
to uh about the past 10 billion years of
the history of the universe to study
expansion of the universe
so it's going to be really exciting by
adding these other uh this other probe
and it's also very flexible if we find
something interesting with Euclid or
other telescopes in the next few years
we're able to tweak the surveys that
we'll do uh with Roman to take advantage
of that and make observations that are
going to help us best pin down uh the
mysteries of dark matter and dark energy
as they exist in 2027 and and is that on
track I mean are you deeply involved in
the mechanics of getting this new
telescope online yes uh I've been
involved with what's now called Roman
for about 20 years under various uh
different names and different stages of
development and one of the things that's
really exciting just in the last few
weeks we've chosen new science teams so
NASA announced the selection of a number
of science teams that is scientists
across the U.S who have often uh
colleagues and counterparts in other
countries who've joined their teams as
well who are going to be funded by NASA
to think about how to use Roman not just
for Dark Energy but the study of
exoplanets and the study of infrared
astrophysics as a whole Roman has a wide
range of goals and capabilities that is
another way that it's set apart from
Euclid Euclid is more like an experiment
to study Dark Energy but Roman is a more
general purpose Observatory that's going
to have lots of different science goals
so we're excited to get these teams on
board and start working with them and
and what do you think is the future of
earth-based
telescopes all of that we're focusing
upon is launching something to go out in
space which I gather above the well
above the atmosphere and not having to
worry about those sorts of distortions
but obviously down here on Earth it can
build something pretty big and you can
service it so I is there a role for both
going forward absolutely yeah a role for
ground-based telescopes and the exciting
ground-based telescope that's going to
come online in 2025 is named after the
dark matter Pioneer Vera Rubin so
there's the Vera Rubin Observatory uh
that's being built in Chile which is
going to do a survey called The Legacy
survey of space and time lsst and this
survey is going to look at the entire
Southern sky so about half of the sky
over the course of five nights but it's
going to repeat that every five nights
for 10 years so it's going to have at
the end an incredibly deep survey and an
incredibly good uh way of measuring what
we call transients uh events that uh
change over time so much of the sky is
static over the course of years or
decades but a lot of things that happen
in the sky are not static like these
exploding Stars supernova and many other
things so Reuben is going to be an
incredible uh resource for studying dark
matter and dark energy but of course a
wide range of other astrophysics and
what I'm most excited about uh
personally is that if you take the data
from Euclid and you take the data from
Roman and you take the data from Reuben
and you uh combine them together in
clever ways starting at the pixel level
I think you're going to have the best
possible constraints on dark matter and
dark energy from that combined data set
and the best possible constraints on a
huge range of other astrophysics topics
so I think what we'll have in the 2030s
is we'll have this archival data set
from the three telescopes that's going
to be transformative and allow for
studies that answer questions we haven't
even thought of yet
I mean I think that's the most exciting
exciting part right I mean part of our
discussion has been how do you confirm
things that we expect based upon you
know a long Legacy a theoretical ideas
observational ideas that have come to
this view that is kind of consensus
right you got a certain amount of matter
a certain amount of Dark Matter certain
amount of dark energy the numbers shift
slightly but whatever 70 Dark Energy
five percent ordinary matter 25 percent
dark something like that you know but
it'd be even more exciting if it all
breaks
and and we're forced to something else
right
absolutely and you know that's the uh I
think that the thing that's most
exciting to scientists is that they do
an experiment and find something that
wasn't quite right and they uh follow
that up and say okay I found something
new and if that happens I think it's
going to be incredibly important for
Euclid uh and then Reuben and then Roman
to find the same thing and confirm the
results of each other because uh you
know as we heard in the first half the
show you know extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence and
having these three telescopes with
different uh observational strategies
different types of detectors and
different teams doing the analysis is
going to be incredibly important for us
believing any new physics that might
come out of these yeah which would be
which would be astounding
so Jason thanks so much for joining us I
mean these are incredibly exciting times
and we wish you all the best going
forward with the mission and we look
forward to what Euclid reveals and as
well as the other
missions that are going to go forward
and why don't we plan to have you back
to give us an update you know sometime
you know after December when the data
starts to pour in I would I would love
to come back uh anytime to talk about
early data or talk about Dark Energy
results uh so I had a great time I
appreciate it and I should say when I
was in graduate school your your uh book
was sort of transformative in my way of
thinking about the universe and so it's
been a real honor for me to to be here
today I appreciate that very much thanks
again for joining us
all right so everybody this is uh
drawing to the end of our live session
here maybe just a quick announcement
number of you have asked about
the live events of the world Science
Festival which of course prior to the
pandemic would occur at the end of May
early June in New York City and those
programs are the ones that we would
traditionally Post in the ensuing months
we haven't done a world Science Festival
of that sort in New York since 2019 we
are going to do a live world Science
Festival in this year 2023 in September
I think it's roughly September 20 to 24.
I could have the dates a little bit off
but roughly the third week in September
so if you happen to find yourself in New
York you should please join us live and
at some point shortly thereafter we will
make the films of those programs
available to you all so we can keep the
vital important conversation about
cunning Edge science going forth with
Vigor and energy I will quickly mention
too there are a number of programs that
I'm particularly excited about at World
Science Festival 2023 but one will be
closer to my heart than all the others
we're going to do a kind of
state-of-the-art update on where we are
with string theory with some of the
leading practitioners Pioneers
developers of the subject in
conversation with me so we will have
Nobel Laureate David Gross we'll have
kumaran vafa from Harvard Andy
strominger from Harvard and one other
person whose name is escaping me I have
no idea why but it must be senility of
my advancing years here but it's going
to be a really wonderful way of
exploring you know where we have been
with all these ideas in unification so
please join us in New York if you were
there but keep an eye out for those
programs as we release them sometime in
early to late fall and probably into
winter of 2024 as always if you have any
particular subjects that you would like
us to take up in one of these live
sessions we're getting back to doing
these on a semi-regular basis please let
us know either in the comments section
or you can always email World Science
Festival and we'll be sure to take a
look and see whether or not we can put
together a program on a subject of
interest to a wide swath of our audience
all right that's all then for today from
World Science Festival signing off from
beautiful Upstate New York look forward
to seeing you at our next live event
which we will announce announce in the
coming weeks thank you all very much for
joining us
[Music]
foreign